okay I want to thank the organizers for
giving me the opportunity to present
some of the recent work that I've been
doing since I've moved from Brown
University to Denmark and then after the
two padova and that's why you will see
that my affiliation is university of
padua but the work that they gonna
present mostly from my students they are
all in Denmark at the moment okay so
there are nowadays we can measure
somatic mutations in many cancer
patients and there are different large
studies that will be conducted for
example by the Cancer Genome Atlas and
international concern Genome consortium
and what the studies have revealed is
that in a typical tumor there are
between hundreds and thousands or even
more mutations while there are probably
and full of driver mutations the turtle
mutations that are related to the
disease or maybe they are related they
could be related to clinical parameters
in the patient so one of the goals in
analyzing the day this day takes to
identify driver mutations that are the
ones that are important for cancer so
many approaches are based on single gene
test in which one can assign essentially
score to a gene and then compare that
score with the distribution for the
score according to an appropriate null
model and then identified geez that in
isolation are significant but I don't
need to say to this audience that of
course looking at jeans in isolation is
not the best thing we can do we should
consider genes in the in the context of
networks in particular because it is
thought that cancer is a disease of
pathways so it is a disease where
mutations driver mutations actually hit
a set of genes that are interacting by
interacting / for certain functions in
the cell so our goal is to identify the
set of genes that are significantly
mutated there are so she aided with the
disease and as we heard in the previous
talk what one can do is to start from
known pathways known set of genes
associated with a certain function and
then one can easily generalize the score
for the single genes to the set and
maybe look at these sets and try to
understand if they are significantly
associated with the disease as we were
the previous talk of course
there's problems including the fact that
we don't know these processes this
approach also looks at these pathways in
isolation without considering the
direction interacting and sometimes only
a part of a set of gene annotated set of
gene may be important for cancer so the
goal would be then to find these mutated
set of genes without restarting to non
pathways and the main problem you are
computationally is that there are the
many candidates set so if we look at all
set of genes even of cardinality up to
six we have more than 10 to the 22
subset so what I'm going to present
today are tomatoes that I've developed
with my student on leveraging on the
formation of large protein-protein
interaction network and combining them
with mutations to identify important
subnetworks for cancer so the first
approach I'm gonna present is a method
to find some network associated with
survival for cancer patients and it is a
paper that will be presented in re combo
next week the second approach is a more
recent work on finding 78 or mutated in
a large fraction of patients that is not
published yet okay before proceeding let
me know that I'm going to talk about
graph I grams and we can think about
these graph algorithms as working on
directly on a protein-protein
interaction network or on a graph that
we can derive from a heat diffusion
process that within the influence graph
in the paper in 2010 at Oracle and these
graphs can be derived as I've been
inscribed for example yesterday by
linear or with other diffusion
approaches on the graph in the mayor is
all we want to do that is that the
degree of the node in the network
actually give us some information about
the confidence that we have been
associating to mutations in a graph so
for example if I have two mutations on
two genes that are connected through a
path of length 2 but that goes through a
gene with a low degree then I can have a
certain confidence that these two
mutations may be associated while if
instead I still have two genes
mutated and they are connected through a
part of leg too but this part moves
through a i'd agree not my confidence
serious reduce that these two mutations
are associated and so by using the
diffusion processes one can try to
correct for this large degree nodes and
one way to do this just at the very high
level is for example to build the an
influence graph in which we are
measuring for each gene in the original
graph in association with the other gene
in the network and we can do this for
all possible jeans so at the end what we
derive is a graph that describe for each
pair of jeans some measure of similarity
or distance if we want to look at
inverse of it basically will be at Oak
later this morning that we describe this
more in Des Moines more in detail okay
so now let's say that we start from our
influence graph and we want to find sub
networks that are associated with
survival so what's the data that we have
for many patients with measured
mutations you know the genes in this
patient and we have time in sensory
information time is the survival time
while censoring is a binary variable
that tells us if the observed time is
the exact time of the event in which
case whether one for the sensor
information or if instead this is on the
lower bound to the survival time of the
patients in which case we have a zero so
now let's assume that we already have a
sub network so for example sub network
of two genes corresponding to these
first two genes in this figure then we
can measure the association of survival
for the subnetwork by splitting the
patients into two groups the patients
that do not have any mutation in these
two genes and the patient that have at
least one of the two genes mutated and
we can derive then the survival the next
amit of the survival distribution for
the two groups for example the right is
the survival distribution for this group
of patients and the blue is the survival
distribution for this group of patients
and by using the known tools from
survival analysis like the log-rank test
we can obtain a p-value that is a
measure of the association of the
significance of the difference in
between the survival of these two
populations
okay so let me say something more about
the log-rank test so the log-rank test
is a nonparametric test that is based
not on the exact survival time of the
patients doesn't look at the time of
Survivor the patient but we only
consider the order in which we observe
the event for the patient so we can
think that when we are performing the
log-rank test for a particular
sub-network ass as we have described
before we are just assigning a group
label to all the patients or we're
dividing the patients in a group 0 or in
a group 1 according to the mutation
status for the patients in that
subnetwork so the log-rank test computes
a lob a statistic that is a function of
the group label and the censoring
information and so what we have is that
we have the weight for each sub network
that depends in theory from the group
label and the sensory information but
since the censoring is fixed in our data
set what we really have from the
log-rank test is simply a work is a wait
for the subnetwork attend okay and what
the log-rank test does then is computed
it give us the probability of observing
a weight statistic at least as Extreme
as the one that we have in our data
under de patas is of no difference in
survival between the two groups of
patient okay so now what we can do then
is use the log-rank statistic the weight
given by the log-rank to define formally
computational problem that we will use
to identify sub-networks associated with
survival so given our mutation data the
survival information and a large gene
interaction network and the value k we
want to find a sub network of k genes
connected that maximizes the log-rank
statistic so the weight given by the
logger so in the paper that is going to
be presented a recon next week we prove
that actually this problem is NP R by
reduction from the set cover problem and
then we present an algorithm called
norma's to identify these networks of
mutations associated with survival
so nomas is bathed on a color coding
algorithm that is a technique that have
been used a lot in bioinformatics and
what it does it identify the sub
networks of mutations associated with
survival and now since we have optimized
to find sub networks such that their
mutations have a high association with
survival we need to test that the
Association for the group that we
observe is actually not due to chance
just to having picked a random set of
genes in the network so what we do we
also perform a permutation test in which
we fixed the mutation the survival time
of the patients and we randomly permute
the identity of the genes in the network
okay so as I said color coding it has
been used a lot in bioinformatics and
these are just some of the papers that
use color coding for bioinformatics
problems now let me give you a short
introduction to ocular coding work so if
we're looking for a sub network of size
k equal to 3 and this is our graph we
now want to find a sub network that
maximizes certain objective function
what we can do is we can random color
its vertex with one of K random colors
obtaining a graph that as the random
colors on the vertices and now once we
fix the coloring of the graph we can
find the eyes coloring color iced
scoring colorful sub graph the tease is
connected sub graph that contains all K
colors pretty efficiently using a
dynamic programming approach and this is
pretty efficient when K is not in
particular one case of the oh is that
most of the order of the loegering of
the number of vertices in the graph okay
so out does it desire in this dynamic
programming approach work well
essentially we built the table which we
have jeans on the rose and the different
color set the different possible subset
of colors that we can have in the
network and for each gene we are going
identify the subnetwork containing
vertices
with those colors and this is actually
data number of vertices that give us the
iced wait so for example if I'm
considering this entry let's say that
these are all correspond to this
specific gene now I'm trying to identify
sub network of two vertices that contain
only vertex that is one blue and the
other one right since I mean this vertex
already of the blue jean and i have now
to consider connected vertices to this
gene data right so i have to candidate
these sub graph in this other sub graph
i can compute the score for each of them
and then I we're according to this entry
the highest-scoring solution and then
when I will try to build a subnetwork
that contains these vertex and will
contain three different colors I will
try to merge this sub network with this
other one okay so if the highest-scoring
subnetwork for our problem is colorful
in our graph we will identify it using
this approach however since we've used a
random color it may be that the best
scoring sub network is not colorful so
what we can do is repeat this approach
many times and at the end we can report
the ice scoring sub graph that we
identify and walk actually proved that
the highest-scoring sub network will be
colorful at least once if one repeat
this process enough times okay so one
can use these approach or a variation of
this approach to for our problem in
which this court that you are optimizing
is the log-rank statistic but what we
have is that if one looks carefully did
the approach for color coding works when
the score is additive so when the score
for a set of gene is the sum of the
score of the single genes the main point
is that for the log-rank statistic the
score that web is not additive so
actually it may be that even if the
optimal solution is colorful in our
graph we may not be able to identify
with this approach in the worst case
however however what we proved in the
page
is that under amount that is a we
believe is kind of reasonable for
mutations in survival if we have enough
samples using the approach based on
color coding we will be able to identify
the optimal solution with guarantees
essentially similar to what we have four
approaches in which the score is
additive so we don't lose anything when
the data comes from a certain
distribution by using the color coding
approach okay so let me now show you the
same result of the application of
Norma's on cancer data this is
essentially ongoing work in particular
for the result that I will show for one
of the sub networks that I will show so
the first thing we have done is we've
compared our approach nomas with two
other algorithms or two types of
vibrance that have been proposed before
for the same problem one is a great deal
i agree which will be the solution
starting from a vertex and adding other
neighbors by trying to maximize the
increase in the solution and another one
is by using an additive score so the
score for a gene for a sub network will
then be just the sum of the p-values for
the single genes for example so by come
yeah its last one I thought you said
that you prove that you can use the
normal Eddie in color coding to find the
highest going network so something is
selection there are some approaches in
the literature that to identify you can
assign to each gene a single score like
the p value for that gene or the
log-rank statistic for just for that
gene and now you've tried to find
sub-network that maximizes the sum of
this course the score for that sub
network though is different from the
score that you get for the log-rank in
our model because now you're looking at
each gene individually and it's
different from taking just the entire
sub network and partitioning the two
patients for that
but in your color coding approach can
you use an additive score no no it's not
additive our score is not additive
that's the main point thanks for
pointing out that it was clear so our
scoring is not added and what we proved
that even you can use an additive score
you're guaranteed to find the maximal
subnetwork know what is saying or I hope
I order it and what I wanted to say is
that if the mutation the opening
solution independent of survival thus
our model and you give me enough
patience this M then nomas our approach
based on the color coding will identify
the optimal solution according to our
score that is not additive but still it
will implement an additive color coding
approach so this no masses now when you
compute the icd when I compute the score
for a subnetwork now I don't add over
the jeans i compute the score for that
sub network and then when i come i
joined to sub networks what i will do is
i will wreck impede the score for that
sub network i just i don't some the
score for the two sub networks so using
that using nomas you first find a sub
Network you see what additive is very
much then you
yes and it's still going to be the best
yes when we try to find these candidates
who use essentially an additive version
but then for each additive were very
computing the new score okay so what we
have when we compare numbers with these
other approaches different variants of
the greedy algorithms that there could
be or by using an approximation
essentially of the score based on the
the sum of the width on the single genes
what we see that Norma's returns
sub-networks that a buyer correlation
with survivor so the ir association with
survivor than the other approaches
sometimes the result the subtitles
detectors are similar but sometimes they
are quite different in particular using
the additive score return sometime sub
letters that are not easily associated
with survival as it is instead by using
the greedy i going or no mas okay so now
let me show you one specific sub network
that we identify using data from
glioblastoma multiforme in TCGA which we
have 263 samples and here we use the
somatic simple nucleotide variants and
copy number aberrations so what we
identify this sub network of eight genes
in which part of the subtitles
correspond to the pi3k akt signaling
pathway and part of the other sub
network correspond contains genes in the
p53 and RB one pathway so there is some
network information and correlation
between these genes and this is the
these are the two survival distributions
for the patients with no mutation in the
set of genes and for the patients with
the mutation in the set og so the these
difference is significant so if one uses
the logger log rank test the p-value is
quite small anybody in addition if one
does this permutation tests on the
network it obtains that it is unlikely
to see a set of eight genes in the
network that show such association with
survival
okay let me point out that none of the
genes in this group is associated with
survival when considered in isolation so
you will not identify this set if you
look even for single genes and tried to
add new genes to it okay so now i'm
going to move to the second problem it
is the problem of finding sub-network
sub-networks mutated in a large fraction
of patients so I presenting this problem
at the end but actually historically we
should have presented it before because
this is a problem that we formulated in
exactly the same way i'm gonna use here
in the paper that was a recon 2010
collaboration with a loop forum with
banner file in which we had two
approaches that we suggested to identify
a set of genes that were mutated in many
patients we caught the first one a
combinatorial model that is what I'm
going to talk about today and the second
one is what we could enhance the
influence mode the nest influence model
should have really been called hot net
because that's what was later called
Latinate even if the name doesn't appear
in that paper and this method is what
then is evolved in a better version that
is now called alternate to add has been
published recently both based on the
influence graph the type described
before okay so what we will do in the
combinatorial mode is identify sub
networks that are mutated in many
patients i'm going to define formerly
the problem in the next slide and then
we will use a permutation test to assess
the significance so just generate a
certain number of permutation looking
the fraction of datasets in which with
identify solution at least as good as
the one we seen regard it okay so in the
combinatorial model formerly the problem
is the volume we take the influence
graph we combine it with mutations in
the sense that what we want to do now is
find for a given value K the subnetwork
the connected sub graph please refresh
graph that is mutated in the maximum
number of samples so this is the problem
and we called it in the paper the
connected maximum coverage problem that
is essentially a graph a version of the
maxim
coverage problem in which you pick K
elements trying to cover as many sets as
possible that is a known NPR problem and
this is the same problem essentially
just with gaurav constraints on the
solutions this is a related also to a
problem from judith key car a Shamir
which they had a different formulation
which they wanted to cover a large to
find the smallest sub connected sub
network that covers they say almost all
samples at least K times and this should
be true for a large fraction of the
patients okay so what we proved in the
paper in 2010 is that this is an mpr
problem is general even it is an fer
probably before simple typologies of the
graph and we propose an approximation
algorithm to solve this problem in the
approximation agron is essentially
generalization of a simple greedy
algorithm in which we be the solution
starting from each vertex and we will
pick the best solution at the end and
for a given vertex we build the solution
starting from the gene looking at paths
that go from that gene to the other
one's path of the certain length and
then we will add to the current solution
the path that give us the the maximum
increasing score but weighted or
averaged over the number of new nodes
that are added in the solution ok so
this was an interesting I corine at the
list and I found out recently that has
been used in other scenarios not that
have nothing to do with the
computational biology so this has been
used in problems in wireless networks
where you want to cover many users by
placing the rooters and they should be
connected so that you minimize some
other function that i'm not sure what it
is what they should it experimental even
for these other problems it worked with
so it worked as well as the approach
they were suggesting at least for the
cases that they could solve ok so the I
agree work well in finding these high
scoring solutions
but is not an exact diagram and while
talking with the collaborator University
of South in Denmark he said that you
think that an IRP solution may be faster
still give a giver of course the best
solution and so while discussing that we
start and working together and so we
came up with a i LP formulation for this
maximum connected coverage problem so
just going to quickly through these ILP
what we want to do is to cover the
maximum number of patients collecting k
subnets k genes that we cover the
patient we cover a patient only if there
is at least one of the genes that we
pick that is mutated in that patient and
then we have to make sure that we have a
connectivity for the DS that we pick and
here the connectivity is defined by this
set of constraints that without giving
too many details require that for each
pair of jeans I&J in the solution if we
look at not separators so it's set of
vertices that if removed we disconnect
these two genes at least one of them
should be in the solution and then based
on this one can use a simple brain
circuit strategy okay so we have
implemented it and then we have compared
the runtime for the ILP with the runtime
for the approximation algorithm and the
greedy algorithm four different data
sets from TCG so what we found is that
actually desire pit quite fast so is
much faster than approximation i agree
with approximation aggregate to compute
many paths and it is also comparable in
running time with the greedy approach so
these i will be that find better
solutions on the data sets that we
identified better in terms of the
coverages of the cover that we identify
better than the covers we see with the
greedy approach or with the
approximation algorithm still the
runtime is comparable sometimes it's
faster than the greedy algorithm and so
it will allow us also to run permutation
tests efficient
so as I said this is work in progress so
I don't have results to show for the
biological networks that we identify
we're evaluating them at the moment but
what we see is that if one then uses the
approximation algorithm to identify
sub-networks evaluate their statistical
significance or uses the ILP to identify
sub networks and then assess their
statistical significance the results can
vary quite a bit so in particular what
we have is that for some of the data set
from TCGA using the ILP we will identify
some significant signal in the data
while using the Proxima Shania actually
we don't identify such such significant
solutions ok so with this and just gonna
acknowledge most people that have done
the work that I presented the first part
of the tokonoma is the work of Tommy
Hanson instead of mine university of
sultan them are in the second part of
the talk is ongoing work with done a
bommersbach that is a student the tank
was supervising with Marco Pierre and
dini my colleague at University of
Southern de mer thank you and if you
have question would be happy to answer I
guess actually was sorry bud
network what do you mean so what we do
once we find the subnetwork it's a a
subgraph the covers a certain number of
patients then we ask what's the
probability that if we permute the
identity of the genes in the network at
random we find the subnetwork with the
same number of genes that covers at
least that many patients now structure
yes significance in terms of the
statistic that we are observing it is
the color as a patient yes pendants of
the patients are now in the optimal
Sandra Photoshop we know examples are
not true do you have a way of testing
done so that you know the contest in
which cancer the mother can be applied
and by saying that we have example where
that is not true you like that there are
me it would not be true as you know if
you have one son I don't have a Quebec
that not because of activity will
generate random mutation and we know
that the public activity is associated
with special final prognosis and he said
breast cancer so then you know you get
the sound of Cassandra you assume that
they're independent of survival when in
fact they are so do you have any way of
testing and that would indicate is going
on fight we haven't tried that no we
didn't try to correct for that actually
that's a great idea and I think is a
great direction for for future work
ideal if one is a way to assess that
then you can split the patients into the
two groups and see what happens but
that's a great point you looked at other
things that have a high wheel weight
fraction so these are things that you
would think would probably be drivers
because they sort of come to dominate
the cancer cells do you see the showing
up in the networks that are survival
succeeded we didn't check that also
because we don't there is some data that
one can use to assess that but for the
many patients that we have the coverage
is not as I if you want to do a very
refined analysis it depends on what you
want to do exactly but yeah that's a
great point and we didn't check for that
correction to music yes you get the
allelic fraction where I guess the
covert user is like 30 X so it depends
what you are really looking for so if
you want to distinguish different things
Michelle that are the exit is enough
then if you just want a safe there is a
correlation between the different what
we see if it is just highly is decidedly
I very tally fractions then they yes but
yeah we didn't check the thread that's a
great idea so in your second part you
said your integer linear programming
paper done for the aggregate yep I mean
I'm just a curious that I mean I'm just
a curious what's a chick you use I don't
think there is a trick honestly that I
was so when I was speaking with my
colleague i was saying exactly the same
thing so that you know the IPO is going
to be slow they hear the trick if you
want it that you can you know again it
is only for this instances that is this
fast there may be of course instance
using which is not going to be as fast
as the gravy the trick is that you can
generate this constraint very
efficiently for your branch and cutter
it's very easy to find the knot
separator that is violated once you have
a solution is not connected data sighs I
guess so these are the number of
patients and I guess we are looking at
sub graph that has 15,000 vertices and
that's the number of edges so
so I wonder if their presentation test
is enough because if you have us so
you're just renaming but for the second
part I guess yes if there is a high
correlation between the degree of the
node and the number of mutation that yes
there would be such a there could be
such an effect that we are not capturing
I have to set it for some other analysis
that we did we checked the correlation
and there is some but is not so strong
that it would completely let's say make
the problem that you will make the
solution not significant so
so for the two parts of your talk you
seem to focus on different things it has
my suspicions people survived the set
point is trying to cover as many
patients yes so do you find a simple not
at all not not at all I should know I
shouldn't say not a thought so for the
GBM one that we showed actually it's
very similar what you would find what
you find with the two methods but they
want there are we have other cases in
which the subnetwork associated with
survival is not the one that is covering
the most patient or in zener there is no
relation between i think their answer
different questions so one is looking
for the survival dissociation of
mutations with survival and the other
ones instead is trying to explain as
many patients as you can essentially try
me to find the Taoiseach's that
explained as many patients as you can
say that those are going to be the
driver mutations for cancer
I guess they are using different signals
and there might be driver mutations that
are not associated with survival like a
simple trivia case is like a mutation in
a gene that is mutated not the patients
with that cancer type there's no
association with survival just because
everybody has it so you cannot even
think about not having it that's a
trivial one but there are many cases of
driver mutations that actually don't
don't have association with survived ok
so i guess if you wanted to get at the
permutation test when you break the
association with survival but preserve
the network you could shuffle peoples
survival status to keep the network to
say
we have tried many different permutation
tests so one is this one that's permit
the identity of the genes that is the
one that actually I like the most
because it's saying with our matter we
are finding a set of genes and we want
to see if the set book makes sense so
you know if it is the connection of
these genes that make sense or not and
then we tried permute the survival of
patients keep the same mutation status
in the permittee survival of the patient
we tried that and they are still
significant we've also tried to keep to
just assigned a mutation in its gene
independently and keep the rest the same
and you guys still significant stuff so
yeah they say I think it's a good way to
do it but you know I'd like this test or
I'll to say it I'm going to address the
earlier question but the other one if I
think wasn't about survival right the
first one was on covering patients so in
that case if you cover patients we are
not looking the survival stuff
thank you thank you